il fallait que je vois un jour à l'autre
supprimer bien sûr c'est le progrès on
peut on peut rien y faire c'est le
progrès c'est triste mais c'est comme ça
[Musique]
j'habite au 4e alors je m'arrange pour
faire ma chambre à peu près alors oui
passe puis quand j'entends ces grosses
pattes arrivé je descends tout de suite
tout est préparé
[Musique]
nous allons arrêter l'exploitation de
transport de la glace c'est pas la
livraison des transports de glace pour
le les glacière de l'Union à partir du
1er avril et alors ces chevaux lui
évidemment sont retirés de la
circulation et je suis bien ennuyé et
pénible d'aller voir partir
à l'abattoir lorsque je voudrais éviter
sur tous ces cela n'est-ce pas j'ai
toujours eu des chevaux toute ma vie et
ce que je voudrais c'est au moment que
de ma retraite que je n'ai pas le regret
d'avoir envoyé ces bêtes
c'est bête à la boucherie
[Applaudissements]
et vous madame qu'est-ce que vous pensez
vous aurez de la peine aussi
mon mari avait aimé beaucoup ses bêtes
et il avait l'habitude tous les jours
quand elle rentrait d'aller les visiter
aux écuries il leur a porté du sucre et
c'est ses chevaux qui avaient l'habitude
de le voir rentrer se retourner tous
regardez sa main pour voir s'il y avait
des morceaux de sucre et même le lécher
même sans sucre lui arrivait lui lécher
les mains alors évidemment ça me fait de
la peine parce que tout ceci va lui
manquer
je souhaite écouter que vous ayez de
nombreux acheteurs nous espérons
d'ailleurs nous allons faire la
publicité pour de façon à ce que c'est
bête ne finissent pas leur vie car ils
ont rendu d'énormes services alors nous
aimerions les voir heureux pour le pour
la fin de leur jour et surtout ce que je
veux l'espace c'est que nous croyez pas
que je veux en tirer un profit parce que
strictement les chevaux sont estimés par
un expert de la boucherie qui en fixera
le prix même quelque chose près je
préfère surtout les ventes à des
particuliers
[Applaudissements]
le kiki
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est votre dernier voyage c'est
mon dernier voyage nous avons entendu et
tout le temps c'est comme ça toute la
matinée on entend ça il y a combien de
temps que vous faisiez ça dans le
quartier ça fait 20 ans que je passe
[Musique]
et puis alors
vraiment c'est un peu triste forcément
tout le temps
presque alors
maintenant
il paraît que vos chevaux se faufilent
bien mieux dans la circulation que moi
vous savez il y a pas de problème moi je
cheval c'est j'ai jamais gêné la
circulation absolument rien du tout et
puis alors sur n'importe quel point de
vue j'ai jamais tombé à quoi
estimez-vous c'est du cette réforme
vous savez ça je suis mal placé pour
vous pour vous le dire mais enfin
je sais que il fallait que les choix un
jour à l'autre soit supprimés bien sûr
je manque forcément il a un gros chagrin
aussi
[Musique]
le progrès on peut on peut rien y faire
c'est
triste mais c'est comme ça
même dans ma situation moi ça changera
parce que j'étais réglé tout maintenant
c'est tout pareil il faut agrandir les
tournées tout ça
vous allez conduire une voiture
maintenant
il va s'en aller à Senlis et je crois
qu'il sera bien parce que j'ai vu le
patron qui l'a acheté on a dû ça tombe
malheureux j'irai voir quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]